our first speaker today is going to be
Brian Garcia he's the program director
for the Yale center of business and
environment he's recently co-founded a
company called earth markets that uses
environmental markets and community
based strategies to accelerate clean and
efficient energy technologies into the
marketplace so Brian let me turn it over
to you and I do want to say one more
thing this this panel is about policy
and standards and I think you're gonna
see how important things like building
codes appliance standards are are to
really getting energy efficiency done in
this country and in the world and
there's a tremendous amount of interest
right now throughout the world to really
enhance and expand things like building
codes get more and better appliance
standards so we have up we have a lot of
thing it's gonna be interesting I'm
going to time you guys on my phone here
and I'm gonna try to keep you all at
about ten minutes so we can get back on
track for Leslie or she may not allow us
to have a break so that's the important
part
so you're on first great thank you Brian
so I am gonna look at this issue of
renewable portfolio standards from the
perspective of a speaker series actually
a webinar series that our Center has
been putting on this year Daniela
Bordeaux and several of her colleagues
who have been helping us lead a speaker
series this year called megawatts on
Main Street whose focus is specifically
around residential energy efficiency and
clean energy so I'm going to approach
the renewable portfolio standard
discussion with the idea that these
policies can help encourage energy
efficiency and renewable energy
development for the residential sector
so that's the the vantage point that
will come at it from just in terms of
the speaker series that we've had so far
these are all the groups and
organizations that we've had talk in the
webinar
these are publicly accessible they're
free online webinars they typically
happen on Tuesdays or Thursdays at
lunchtime so for those Eastern Standard
Time for those of you who are interested
in tuning in we've had a variety of
conversations around these four issues
our general philosophy here with the
residential sector is that no single
solution is going to solve no single
approach is going to solve the problem
of energy efficiency whether that's
coming up
with creative financing mechanisms or
public policies you also need the
consumer marketing and advancing
technology so we approach this speaker
series with these four things in mind
and I'm specifically you're just going
to talk about policy and finance as it
applies to RPS standards so we've all
seen this slide many times this comes
from Laurie Byrd in the speaker series
this is just real quickly an overview of
all the different portfolio standards
happening across the country this speaks
to one important thing in the US which
is that the policy innovation around
clean energy and energy efficiency has
been happening at the state level for a
long time so as we start to enter the
discussion of what will the federal
government do we start raising issues
around hopefully they're establishing
floors rather than ceilings for states
but allowing states to continue to
innovate around policies specifically
I'm going to focus on one state in
particular I've been doing some work
recently in the state of Arizona so
we're going to look at their 15% by 2025
renewable portfolio standard target so
in terms of this target they do have a
distributed generation carve out for
their portfolio standard that's four and
a half percent of sales by 2025 and it's
important now that I think we're
learning about RPS standards and having
a distributed generation aspect to it
specifically in states like Connecticut
where over 96 percent of RPS compliance
comes from other states not in
Connecticut so we're not encouraging
local development but in fact
encouraging economic development in
other states so you're starting to see
this emergence of distributed generation
aspects within portfolio standards in
Arizona has one-half of that distributed
generation standard is required to come
from the residential sector so here's
another sector that we're talking about
that's been left out of the market
historically when you look at our PS
standards you've got your United
Technologies your Walmart's all your big
commercial and industrial companies that
are able to take advantage of these
markets they've got legal staffs people
who understand how to take a project and
monetize renewable energy credits in the
market well households don't have that
capability so it's great to see that
there's a recognition that households
who are paying typically 50% of the cost
of these policies are now going to be
receiving benefit
from these policies so Arizona has a two
and a half percent of sales target by
2025 they also have a different
renewable energy credit than we're used
to we're all typically used to a
megawatt hour produces one renewable
energy credit they are one rec is one
kilowatt hour in that kilowatt hour also
translates into thirty four hundred and
fifteen BTUs so they're bringing the
thermal side into this equation which is
great solar thermal applies to their RPS
standard so just another metric to think
about in terms of what they offer
residential homeowners in the solar PV
space specifically they're going from a
$3,000 per kilowatt incentive they're
lowering that down to just a little over
$2,000 and what that actually does is
that actually allows the state of
Arizona to access more federal funding
because the lower state incentive you
have the higher cost you the the higher
costs the consumers are paying the more
they're able to pull back from the
federal investment tax credit so you
have a policy here that's helping to
actually help the state of Arizona shift
the burden to the federal government a
little bit more here and just in terms
of the economics for the household
you're looking at a payback that drops
from nine years or the increases from
nine years to twelve years
so as Arizona changes their policies
here we're actually seeing an extension
of the payback period to the residential
consumer so from a net present value
perspective we could actually see that
the the homeowner loses about thirty
five hundred dollars of value because of
this change in the policy and lastly I
think this is an interesting piece to
this policy is that actually in terms of
the upfront incentive that households
can receive they can actually receive an
incentive of 120 percent of the actual
load that that residential household
uses so if you're actually creating
power plants now from residential
homeowners from this Arizona RPS so I
think from there I'm going to now jump
to energy efficiency portfolio standards
this is also another slide from Lori
Byrd and we're going to talk
specifically about Connecticut the
National Renewable Energy Lab talks a
lot about the state of Connecticut being
somewhat of a model or at least an early
adopter of this portfolio standard
great so Connecticut's target and just
real quickly let me step back one
renewable energy credit in the in
Connecticut's energy efficiency market
is essentially equivalent to a thousand
kilowatt hours of verified electricity
reduction so Connecticut's policy is 4%
by 2010 that comes to approximately
1,200 gigawatt hours in terms of the
market rough rule rule of thumb by
statute the law says that the ceiling
price on these renewable energy credits
will be 55 dollars the regulator changed
that price lowered it to 31 dollars
based upon utility run incentive
programs and where their average price
fares based upon the programs that they
support there's also a floor price of
$10 established by statute but the
regulator recently made a decision that
you know because you could have a lot of
people in the market essentially
providing say 1500 gigawatt hours of the
look of energy efficiency and they would
all receive a $10 floor price but we had
the consumer council argue that
ratepayers
are gonna pay this increased burden for
efficiency so they actually threw out
this floor price in the market by the
regulator which has caused a lot of
problems in Connecticut from my view on
the Connecticut market I think the
policy was very innovative in its
upfront design in terms of its execution
it's been a hundred percent failure in
terms of attracting private sector
investment in terms of measurement and
verification that the regulator supports
to participate in this market they
definitely support deemed savings Dean
savings are an approach that utility run
programs have used for years which is to
study how well different interventions
have led to reductions from households
they develop algorithms they then say if
we've installed X number of CFLs in a
state then we expect to receive this
amount of kilowatt hours per year for
this number of years so it's just an
alpha an equation or an algorithm we
actually proposed on some others a
large-scale data analysis which is
actually looking at build data the
regulators don't like this and actually
for them it was too complicated to
think about so for us that caused a lot
of problems around measurement and
verification because we believe lsda is
a higher order of verification my to my
point the market is broken we would say
because a hundred percent of the
renewable energy credits that were sold
in this market in 2007 came from the
utility run incentive funds so in no way
has this market actually encouraged
private sector development to support
renewable energy so you effectively have
a double dipping this fund receives 100
million dollars a year from ratepayers
to invest in commercial residential and
industrial projects they take those
savings put those into this market and
get more money effectively to reuse and
recycle back in the economy and last
thing is we had a residential
aggregation allowed in Connecticut's as
a decision by the regulator we have like
one or two more minutes two more minutes
great so the regulator now allows for
residential aggregation in this market
it took a lot to get there we fought
with the utilities to get that that
happened and then suddenly what happened
is you saw ten private sector companies
come into the state of Connecticut to
want to provide efficiency and this was
the business model that a lot of us were
pushing which is a lighting CFL model
which is no different than what you're
seeing in the Clean Development
Mechanism markets and the carbon markets
we want to go into homes we want to take
out inefficient incandescent and install
CFLs from that we have an independent
measurement and verification expert come
in and say here's our estimated savings
from that project we then generate
renewable energy credits over the life
of that bulb in some cases six to eight
years those renewable energy credits
hopefully pay for the upfront investment
and give a return back to the investor
this was the model a lot of parties came
in with this is what we had conceived
coming into this market the what the
regulator ended up doing was really
discounting the useful life of the
measure because of the federal phase-out
of incandescent light bulbs so the
regulator came in and said since CFLs
start phasing out in 2012 the 2014 we're
not going to give you the full measure
life we're only going to give you 2 to 4
years of that measure life which
destroys the project finance model so
therefore you're left with the utility
program problems
the current price for energy efficiency
in Connecticut this is the this is a
graph of from 2000 to 2008 of the cost
of energy efficiency from the utility
run programs so we see that
to deliver a kilowatt hour of savings
today costs about 25 cents so if they're
investing a hundred million dollars a
year to get kilowatt hour savings today
that comes to about 25 cents now in
comparison to what the private sector
might be able to deliver in a portfolio
standard market if you take a ten-year
useful life of a measure you assume a
rec price in this case on the left hand
we assume a C a class 3 RPS alternative
compliance payment price which is 31
dollars at ten years we net present
value that price and we compared against
the utilities so we're pretty equal so
we're talking about this Left bar chart
here about 25 cents for that kilowatt
hour savings compared to what the
utility run system benefit funds are
doing well the market is more
competitive than that so we're not going
to see a $31 ceiling price we're
actually going to see something less so
when we run that number at $20 or $10 we
can actually see that the private sector
can deliver kilowatt hours more
efficiently in this market than the
utility run system benefit fund programs
so that was the mark so a lot of this is
to say that as the nation thinks about
having energy efficiency portfolio
standards that as a national strategy
there needs to be ways for us to cap
utility participation in this market
they dominate this market given the
various incentives that they provide so
what we actually proposed in Connecticut
which was supported by Kimberly Clark
and other industrials is a cap 25%
that's all the utilities can do anything
above that private sector should deliver
so those are some cons of Connecticut
real quickly pros on the RPS we're
seeing the emergence of digital
distributor generation requirements this
is good for local development and jobs
on the con side we're seeing the
exportation of jobs so Connecticut's
renewable energy market is clearly
evidence of that you're seeing a lot of
legislators now talk about stopping
sending our RPS dollars to Maine New
Hampshire and Vermont and that will be a
constant conversation energy efficiency
portfolio standards the pros there you
get really strong performance-based
efficiency in this market through
independent measurement and verification
and you can also significantly reduce
RPS costs when you combine efficiency
with renewables and then the con is what
I've talked about just in terms of
putting a cap on utility participation
you have to really limit their
participation in the market to encourage
private sector investment I think that's
it thank you Brian
great ok our next speaker is going to be
Bill Faye
bill is the executive director of the
building energy-efficient codes Network
and the energy efficient codes coalition
two very important organizations that
the Alliance works on very closely with
Bill and Bill lemon let you tell
everybody about it good good is this
microphone working it's the only one
without a light on okay good that's fine
all right great well I have I have the
great distinction today to talk about
probably in ten minutes
something that has is both incredibly
arcane and also underappreciated that's
the the code system in the United States
the compendium that we're publishing is
good is going to note and I quote four
countries and states interested in
improving the energy performance of
buildings auditing it up and adopting an
up-to-date energy code is an important
first step and I think that that that
that it's important for one very simple
reason if you're a new building is going
to last seventy to a hundred years which
means that either the build that
buildings efficiency or inefficiency is
going to be with us through 2080 or 2110
if you can imagine that so so you now
start to understand where it is and we
also have and I'm going to discuss each
at each facet of code development and
adoption and implementation and other
things but as you go through each of
these what you realize is that we really
are in many areas far behind we have
some innovators and I want to discuss
some of those today but as I go through
some of the facets of building codes I
want to I want to touch on some of the
lessons that have been learned by those
who are the innovators and then I want
to focus more thoroughly on the local
leadership aspect of of the presentation
I think again quoting the compendium
there must be real political support
from local government local officials do
need to be involved and a truly
dedicated staff
championing the effort now there's no
place that I can imagine that that has a
better champion than John Hogan in in
Seattle because John's been with the
program for 30 years which is about as
long as Seattle's habbits energy code
and and when you talk to John you know
he he really does touch on each of these
elements and I'm about ready to discuss
and and it's it's it's wonderful to have
him involved in code development
hearings all the way through to the to
the implementation you know when you
take a look at what Seattle's learned
over the years you know the first thing
that John will tell you is that they
brought everyone together and I think
that that's the key step at least in in
order to to ensure that you have some
sense of adoption or of support for the
codes that are adopted and and and John
did that has done that very well in
Seattle they also did an extensive
training program not only for the code
inspectors and for those that are
implementing the the program but also
for the community
and reaching out to the building sector
as well to try to train them each time
that the codes are updated to ensure
that that that practice is there and
they have a very assiduous attention to
that that effort and then lastly they
learned that we really that one of the
most critical elements of ensuring that
that code is is properly implemented is
to have is to start out right and have
the right kind of plan review and then
end up with the right kind of inspection
of that kind of process so those those
are just things that they've noted that
they've learned over the years that are
that they would impart to others Dakota
County Minnesota is another one of the
case studies that's in the compendium
and what you're going to find in there
is that they learned learned really two
things first of all they are sharing
their ideas very much with with other
local governments kind of become
somewhat of a mentor to and to other
counties and other other programs around
there but secondly they also understood
right off the bat that there wasn't
there was a lot of resistance to codes
and so they they armed everyone that
worked with in in in the
Kota County program with the arguments
on costs with the business the business
argument for energy efficiency
and believe me that really is critical
when it comes to acceptance of those
those codes that are out there now
Austin has taken this a little farther I
think it's great to know that Austin had
a mayor that was an engineer and that
and and will win did a phenomenal job
not only bringing in a very strong
program involving the utility Austin
Energy but but also most recently
establishing a requirement that energy
audits had to be completed before the
home was sold as a condition of the of
the home sales and so to talk to kind of
reference the or maybe change the
direction of where Tip O'Neill might
advise virtually all code politics is
indeed local when I take a look at that
local activity and you look at the five
critical elements of codes the the first
one is model code development when you
when you understand right off the bat
that it's the model code that shapes
state and local codes and then in
addition to that and this is kind of a
stunning thing it is adopted by the
local officials now that may seem like
something many of you know very
implicitly but but at the US Conference
of Mayors meeting in Washington DC where
we'll win was the chair of the Energy
Committee he looked out over his fellow
mayors and said how many of you knew
that the model code was adopted every
three years or renewed every three years
not a mayor raised his or her hand and
and the second question was how many of
you knew that it's your employees the
code officials that actually cast the
votes that adopt that model code and
again no one raised their hand and that
was an astonishing thing and it it
really put into and it really started
the US Conference of Mayors to getting
very involved in the code development
process for the first time that they had
really been engaged my group put
together the 30% solution which was the
first time that the model code process
had ever encountered a comprehensive
proposal that boosted energy efficiency
by 30
and you know what we also work very much
with those mayors and others to ensure
that those votes were there that the
code officials came that those local
leaders were there we there were and and
this is actually something that I think
I would encourage on virtually every
state Virginia and Colorado are again
very very thorough in making sure that
they send strong delegations it's it's
kind of an unusual thing but but every
city has allowed for eight or twelve
people to come and vote on the model
code there are tens of thousands of
potential eligible votes and the last
code was adopted by a hundred and
fifty-eight votes you know so this is
this is I mean we aren't getting that
kind of local I mean we sometimes do
with Virginia and in Colorado and I also
will point out that that for the first
time because of the effort that the
mayor's did the effort that EE CC did we
had 64% of the code officials and
attendants voting in favor of energy
efficiency now we needed 2/3 to adopt
the 30% solution so we felt a little
short but we did adopt a model code that
was 15% beyond any code that the the
previous code and that was the first
time we'd seen a sizeable increase in
energy efficiency the model code for
some time now that's critical because
that's what lays the groundwork for
additional efforts and Congress has has
told states that that in in accepting
era money that they also have to begin
working on the adoption of that code so
the model code process is something that
doesn't usually find its way into
discussions about building codes but the
involvement of the local official is
absolutely critical and we've got
another one coming up at the in in
October in Charlotte North Carolina and
based on the recommendations made so far
by the development committee code
officials from all around the country
will have the opportunity to adopt a
code that is going to boost a
residential energy by nearly 40 percent
and commercial energy by 30 percent and
eliminate the one competing weaker code
that's in the ICC Icode process the IRC
energy chapter so these are just
understanding the importance of that
model code and underst
there's a local role in the development
of it I think is absolutely critical the
second out that the the next element and
probably very almost more important is
the local and state code adoption here I
think finding ways for states and
localities to work with groups like B
cap the Building Code assistance project
or Rica the responsible energy code
Alliance is absolutely critical because
we are fate we are battling war in the
States in terms of adoption right now
Ohio is look is working on weakening its
code there's a bill in front of the
Georgia Legislature that would eliminate
the body that is responsible for setting
the model code or setting the code in in
the state of Georgia at the same time we
have great leadership going on by cities
the city of rockville maryland city of
the District of Columbia in both
instances said we're not comfortable
with just the model code we are we're
going to focus on a 30% beyond code so
the next two elements are compliance
appraisals and in both of those
instances again Congress is starting to
get involved with with different
mandates working with the green builder
count programs and bit green builder
college and utility programs one of the
things that's most critical we're now
talking to Congress about the idea of
improving appraisals and I think that
really is what gets at the the one of
the major impediments to support from
the hat from the building community and
we're starting to find that the builders
I've actually had the president of one
of the builder of one of the largest
home builders in the country say I will
build a home that's 70% beyond code if I
can have those improvements reflected in
the appraisal and so I can make that
make the money out there back on this
and so we are working very closely with
builder groups not only the small guys
but also the big guys to try to work on
ways to improve the appraisal process I
notice I'm running out of time but we
have a we have a number of different
opportunities here in the leadership
we're seeing at the local level has been
absolutely critical at all LM
this and and lastly it's been it's been
critical most importantly with the code
code adoption and and then the ultimate
of implementation thank you great thank
you Bill
our next speakers are going to be Blair
Hamilton Blair is the policy director
from the Vermont energy Investment
Corporation the EIC like me
bills Blair's had about 30 years in a
broad scope of energy efficiency and
he's best known in the United States for
his leadership in forming what we like
to call the first energy efficiency
utility in the country so Blair I was
asked the tango says talk about system
benefit charges I'm gonna try to be true
to that charge but I may stretch the
envelope just a little bit in my in my
eight minutes here really back up for
men because this we're here because of
climate and I guess I need to say energy
efficiency is increasingly recognized as
a central part of any strategy to
achieve climate goals it's low risk it's
proven it's reliable but I think
increasingly it's also recognized it's
the least cost option and that with all
of the focus on well what's it going to
cost to achieve climate goals the more
efficiency we do the lower the cost and
so with all due respect I spent half my
life working on in renewable energy but
in terms of what do we need to do a
whole lot of to reach climate goals and
have it be something that we can get
support behind but in terms of the cost
it is a lot of efficiency essentially
the piece I'm going to talk about is
that part of efficiency resources and
reduced use who's separating those
because they're really two different
elements one's be more efficient in the
way we do things but also reduced use
like buying a smaller home or a smaller
appliance not just getting a more
efficient
one but really what we're trying to do
is close that gap as sustainable energy
resources ramped up we need to bring
down the curve until those meet then the
sooner the better
how much well I'm going to just go out
there and make a suggestion I think
increasingly what we see from people who
are trying to do the max about how do we
reach climate goals whether it's
scientists or researchers or national
governments increasingly the kind of
numbers I'm seeing are people saying
we're going to have to get at least half
of our carbon reductions from efficiency
and I would suggest you know from work I
was doing in Europe in the last few
months a lot of people are talking about
scenarios that look to about 60% from
efficiency 20% from on-site zero carbon
generation either biomass or solar and
then the other 20% coming from
decarbonized grid supply depending on
where you are in Europe that means
massive offshore wind in the north and a
lot of solar in Spain and North Africa
and those numbers add up to a hundred
percent not eighty percent because
people are also planning that in the
building sector and in the
transportation sector we have to be
going for a hundred percent of
decarbonisation because we're going to
use all of the carbon that we can afford
to put into the atmosphere is going to
be coming from agriculture and from
certain industries and we have the
ability and the lowest cost way to go is
for the building of the transportation
sector so we should shoot for a hundred
percent there so back to system benefit
charges there are a lot of different
policies and a lot of different funding
that can lead us toward that goal it's
important to recognize that however in
this in this country it is utility
ratepayers
the deficiency which has been the
biggest contributor to making these
kinds of reductions in the building
sector according to this is a church
from the Consortium for energy
efficiency saying that in the US last
year these utility rate payer funded
efficiency programs total around 5.3
billion dollars which is a pretty big
contribution but it's actually in in
most of these programs if you look
across the board typically it is that
public investment that is leveraging a
lot of private investment we need to be
pushing that even further through the
kind of loan programs that were talked
about earlier and very aggressive
financing but even today it comes out
about one-third two-thirds that is
grants incentives and technical
assistance at the order of five billion
are likely inducing building owner
investment on the order of ten billion
again a big number but if I go back to
the goals regrettably we need to be
doing at least twice that much if we're
going to hit 2050 in the building sector
there's a lot of variation by state when
we look at these utility rate payer
funded programs you see Vermont there on
the top on a per capita basis at in 2009
around $50 per capita you also see some
that are well in fact all the states
aren't even on the chart because some of
them are zero and our mean per capita is
only around 12 now I guess the other
thing to be be clear about here one of
the beauties of this is this is put
forward based on a legislative and
regulatory policy framework it's not
coming from carbon it's not coming from
social policy environmental policy it's
basically just the pure
genomics from a utility perspective you
know our chart there from our last
year's annual report the investments we
made of rate payer funds and bought
energy services for Vermonters at two
point nine cents per kilowatt hour
and every kilowatt hour that we saved if
utilities had gone out and bought
comparable supply at the margin because
the kilowatt hour you save is the last
one they had to go out and buy so it's
the most expensive and if they had
bought say a kilowatt hour worth of
savings for the next 20 years as
comparable to an efficiency measure at
our current avoided cost that's 14 cents
per kilowatt hour one can look at this
and say efficiency is a really great
deal I also look at this and say oh my
god we're under investing way you know
people are paying a whole lot more for
supply because we aren't doing enough
efficiency so again you can see where we
could be doing two or three times as
much and it's still cheaper than supply
or as many people have pointed out as a
carbon strategy it has negative cost it
costs less than business as usual so
just real quick a little bit about how
this is played out in Vermont our energy
efficiency utility was initiated with
system benefit charges every every
retail consumer in Vermont pays a
volumetric charge on their electric bill
we've certainly added in some other
funds in terms of carbon revenues our
participation in region forward capacity
market but if I'm primarily founded on
the notion of the system benefit charge
all of the utilities over 20 of them
collect this charge and it goes into an
efficiency fund our regulator has
appointed an entity the organization
happens to be a nonprofit that I
co-founded and directed to fulfill the
utilities least cost efficiency
pyramid requirements the utilities in
the 90s had the responsibility they were
required to do this Vermont decided we
could do better to have a single program
statewide and to have an entity that was
completely mission aligned with this
purpose establish this idea of an
efficiency utility but this is not seen
as this is part of utility system cost
it's paid just like of all other utility
costs so it it's not a si it's not a tax
it is a cost of utility service and the
way that we've established this in
Vermont with the efficiency utility it's
a competitively selected entity that
delivers this on a performance-based
basis so for instance in the current
three-year period
we need to deliver a certain number of
megawatt hours a certain number of peak
megawatts and a halt a little slew of
other performance indicators for a fixed
price the results being that in doing
this over then this is both history and
our projected numbers going forward the
top of the green there is the average
one-and-a-half percent load growth that
Vermont has as underlying interestingly
one half percent is almost exactly what
E is as the whole country is doing on
electricity and the green is our
increasing savings and since 2007
Vermont became the first state to
through solely through energy efficiency
turn that load growth curve negative and
maintain that now for several years so
couldn't help but putting the little
quote there from dr. chu and thank you
thank you
our final speaker on this panel is Paul
savage of the CEO of next tech power
system and he's been a founding
governing member of the emerge Alliance
corporation currently a member of the
Clinton Global Initiative and also
remember the board of directors of
Winrock international a really great
group that does a lot of work in many
many countries and brings the standard
of living up for many people so Paul
it's all yours thank you and let me
apologize in advance for not getting to
everything I wanted to tell you today
how like last year I changed the whole
idea of what I wanted to say today
because of what happened the day before
and that turned into a short paper that
turned into a long paper and in the pre
publication that we just saw today or I
just saw today so thank you real and
reap and and all you acronyms for it
giving me that opportunity to flesh out
an idea and if you become interested in
the the idea behind what I'll be talking
about here in standards please refer to
that article that's called the DC
microgrids benefits and barriers and
Brian if you give me a two-minute
warning of you thank the morning so the
idea of a standard the title Leslie gave
me I you know standards just they're
killing aren't they it's you don't know
whether it's a flag a banner or a book
like a phone book and a beige jacket
then you want to avoid my stand the I'm
an advocate for DC power standards and I
mean that in the flag version as in the
thing you hoist on the battlefield
to rally troops behind you there are for
my purposes three basic kinds of
standards electrical and mechanical and
control standards these are what are
going into the smart grid as it's been
described in the Energy Act
2007 interestingly electrical and
mechanical have been the domain of OSHA
the federal Occupational Safety and
Health Administration control not so
much although it's coming coming to be
yeah I am fresh from the I Triple E
transmission and distribution conference
down in New Orleans which is what made
me decide to change what I wanted to say
because it's so dominated by Cisco you
can't believe it in fact they between
when we decided who is going to be in
our panel about transmission
transmission and distribution and when
it was delivered Cisco had hired 40% of
the panelists I think not
not on purpose exactly but it does show
you how things are changing and it's
happening very quickly if you think of
quadrants this is a little bit meant to
confuse you know language can equally
confuse or clarify for you so let's go
through public private and involuntary
involuntary you know no one my Microsoft
got into the software business they did
not go to the government to help them
promulgate the standard they just did it
unlike electrical standards which the
government did step in in the 20s and
30s to help organize the then Mason
electricity business for the good of the
country and the interoperability of
those systems resist them see das see
Don and us from that that was kind of a
backwards effort by the scientific
community that was behind the original
operating systems that got us to where
we are today the National Electric Code
where to come from surprisingly it's
over a hundred years old and almost
nobody knows and I know this because I
know almost nobody that the
the National Electric Code was created
by Rhian directly really a bunch of
insurance companies they're having their
there their lunch eaten by all these
early electrical systems that were
burning things down at an alarming rate
and so they created the National Fire
Protection Association that is a
non-profit established by insurance
companies who we're losing too much
money to fire so there's a terrific
model back in our history for why you'd
create codes in the first instance and
it had to do with risk and I think that
the kinds of codes that I'm an advocate
for these days in addition to my day job
are exactly the same the same kind of
thing acceptance instead of fire risk
it's really a environmental risk the
risk of not capturing the efficiencies
that you could code today as a an
amazing phalanx of sections and people
that are in turn interpreted by another
an amazing collection of state and local
building inspectors and other
authorities having jurisdiction and then
of course Chicago which is a different
from all those other things so if you
look at today's theater what do we have
you have absolute confusion I would say
although a lot of people wouldn't admit
it
especially chairs of codes committees
they see no they see no confusion at all
when in fact there's a great deal of it
and you can and there's good examples of
this because people are using the same
words to describe different concepts and
they're using the same concepts with
different words I see it all the time
there's so much crosstalk in what's
happening between the stationary and the
mobile environment you know
National Fire Protection Association
which is the the owner of the code are
now working with a society of automotive
engineers because there needs to be this
interaction between mobile and
stationary power systems you can imagine
what those conversations are like there
is zero parts commonality today between
the stationary and and the mobile power
systems none absolutely none
and so it's very interesting to see them
come together in the dark and try to
figure out what's happening Cisco I
mentioned infrastructure mismatches if
you looked at a lot of the efforts that
are implicit in the grid the smart grid
effort that's from the Energy
Independence and Security Act sorry of
2007 if you look at the goals of the
smart grid
they rely a lot on IT and communications
leverage it's just that the IT and
communications network doesn't have the
30 40 50 year design life that most of
the major elements in the utility have
so you've got all these semiconductor
wingnuts trying to come up with ways to
harden all their systems so that they
look more like a transformer and that's
great because they need to and so that's
that's what's happening I'm guessing one
close to two minutes am i right okay
so now I will I've told you I was an
advocate now I will advocate we started
with five other companies about 18
months ago something called the
emergence to promote DC power standards
as a way to promote greater efficiency
for all appliances especially electronic
ones but also to improve the efficiency
of on-site distributed power and the
integration of storage which is also DC
renewables like solar PV and the small
wind turbines and batteries are all DC
devices just like electronics and so the
logic goes if you create these networks
of DC power and buildings you can
improve the efficiency of the whole lot
well it's been tremendously success
so far we've got over 60 companies
including the Lawrence Berkeley labs and
a couple of big utilities that are
excited about adopting DC power
standards as a way to promote efficiency
goals and to obtain their smart grid
objectives that's a picture of the one
of our systems we're actually delivering
low voltage DC power through the metal
grid of the ceiling there that's an
Armstrong product Armstrong makes over a
billion square feet a year of suspended
ceiling systems that's right over a
billion square feet a year of suspended
ceiling systems and now they have a way
of distributing on that conductor you
see in the picture low voltage DC power
that's class to power below the shock
hazard which will also advance safety
because the number one killer of
electricians is working on a hot
lighting system the US Green Building
Council cares that's their intergalactic
conference room and in Washington DC
that's where they have meetings with
other galaxies the US Green Building
Council the lab group that's that that's
another installation I just want to show
a few pictures in lest you feel it was
only my idea the Los Angeles County
Community College District at the
community college system in California
is the largest customer of solar in
California that's probably not gonna be
true this year anymore but it has been
true for three or four years SoCal
Edison my pals there that's one of the
two utilities who are involved and
they're evaluating a couple of systems
as ways of reaching their goals for
rooftop solar of course what I'm talking
about doesn't have any impact on solar
fields but the extent to which you're
interested in land-use issues ought to
make you favor rooftop solar anyway and
integrating it higher efficiencies ought
to be your primary goal so if you go to
the emerge Alliance org
homepage you can see who the other folks
are in the effort and it's extraordinary
really
you have building materials
manufacturers you've got electrical
goods manufacturers then you have steel
case that makes desks and then you have
SoCal Edison you've got the other kinds
of controls organizations so I have a
look at it and and you can find out more
there and so my idea of a standard is is
exactly the battlefield example which I
think interestingly depends on the staff
at the end of wreath to raise itself up
above the battlefield business there
Rachel that's for you that's right the
standard depends on the staff so thank
you that's good thank you Paul great
okay how about two or three questions
well I'm gonna go five minutes here I
think you heard some interesting topics
yeah okay Bob block of green city's
green villages I've got a question for
Paul Savage about the DC there are two
questions I have about it one is the
advantage of this relative to AC and
vice-versa for long-distance
transmission and the second you've got a
lot of appliances and devices that are
AC you know they're already in existence
they cost less because they're
mass-produced there's a problem there
how do we deal with those two problems
on the transmission side of things not
my bag but I would tell you that between
service territories there's always a DC
link so that when you bring up a dead
grid you don't have to get synced with
the grid next year and there is there is
actually more long-distance DC transit
you would imagine but it really has
nothing to do with what I'm talking
about what I'm talking about has is
really at the edges of the grid it's a
way of giving the grid Headroom and
advancing these smart grid goals in a
more robust way more cheaply and with
greater efficiency on the what to do
about the installed base that our first
targets are commercial and industrial
loads like the ceiling where things are
hardwired or you think of them as
hardwired not not plug loads but this is
the entire concept behind the emerge
Alliance is to promote a standard
because if there were one then you would
get you would think redundant you know
billions and billions and billions of
power supplies so it's a trivial
undertaking for Dell to pick a name to
make their laptop work on 24 volts DC
which is our that's the first standard
we've promulgated for electrical devices
in the occupied space so the long term
goal is that people make things to
operate on 24 volts which means you can
avoid the the lossy conversion at the
device and take advantage of a higher
efficiency conversion at greater power
levels in the building there might be a
unifying issue here back in the early
30s there was a group called technocracy
that we're promoting eggs to replace the
gold standard as currency I believe in
the early 70s Mark Hatfield introduced a
similar principle could you perhaps all
of you reflect on currency based
currency that would not only work at the
utility levels you know reggie's of the
world but also it's a consumer base
level are you talking about things with
electricity credits or I'm not familiar
with
we're talking about energy as a means of
transactional currency you know you've
had gold based currencies you have
currencies backed by other you know
commoditized manifestations
what about ones that are backed by toads
you mean instead of a hard asset you
want a service free to back your
currency or do you want the power plant
to back your currency no I mean we're
reducing for example in the case of the
wreck - what 1350 to be to use that the
30 for 15 or so 30 something of that
nature but the point is that you know at
this juncture you know we even at the
nano level are able to gauge what
energies are generated you know we can
put mechanisms on people's knees for
example the principle being that if you
now have a currency that is energy based
you can begin to get the consumer market
to start having transactional
interactions using that as a basis
thereby is in effect your monetizing all
these various levels of service not just
at the levels that we're seeing and now
carbon credits or things of that caliber
but all the way down to the consumer
level so you don't mean money you mean
the market well we're getting into the
maybe semantics here I probably do mean
it would be a version of money yes it
would be a currency well one of the
things that I think brought Cisco do you
go back to the example into the market
is this a concept of having trillions of
transactions going on between devices
and their sources that there's a whole
lot of intelligence that will go into
that and the awareness of the appliances
will create these transactions and you
have lots of inputs that will go into a
time of day peak pricing it'll be
based on the fuels going in tell you
this huge a database of inputs variables
that will you know work work that market
and and a requirement of that is that
you have all the loads be sufficiently
aware as to be able to be one side of a
transaction so in that sense I think
it's coming like a freight train
I would just say in terms of the
challenge of monetizing residential
energy efficiency
you've got the issue of measurement and
verification right so how do you truly
know that what a homeowner is taking is
actually leading to reduction so you
aren't truly creating a commodity so to
speak you're you know maybe with the
CFLs you can you can show incandescent
before and after it's pretty clear but
when you start doing other things like
insulation and you know other measures
it's hard to really truly understand
what reductions you're leading to with
measurement and verification that we use
so trying to get to that transaction is
harder on the renewable side it's pretty
clear you just meter it and here's a
production issue credits it's pretty
clear on renewables efficiency it's
tougher to get to that commodity
transaction all right well we're gonna
we're gonna cut this off now because we
do have to go to break I just want to
say I think that we in both panels this
morning I think we've really had some
good discussions about about the number
of best practice or maybe in deference
to Keith Wilkes at least pretty good
practices you know I think they're I
think they're excellent practices I
think gonna hear more this afternoon and
again these are these are really
critical to getting getting a market
transformed out there and getting
efficiency accelerated into that market
so again thank you all very much good